NUGGETS THROUGHOUT THE AFTERNOO
AFTERNOON.
AS WE CONTINUE, PETER DOOCY IS
UP IN WASHINGTON WITH SOME INFO.
PETER?
>> WE'VE NOW HEARD FROM THE TOP
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS,
NANCY PELOSI WHO SAID SHE'S NOT
INTERESTED IN PURSUING
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS AT ANY
POINT AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND CHUCK SCHUMER WHO SAID,
LET'S JUST WAIT FOR THE MUELLER
REPORT.
I'M GOING TO READ FROM YOU A
JOINT STATEMENT FROM BOTH PELOSI
AND SCHUMER.
IT SAYS THAT NOW SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER HAS SUBMITTED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, IT'S
IMPERATIVE FOR MR. BARR TO MAKE
THE FULL REPORT DOCUMENT AND
PROVIDE ITS UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS
AND FINDINGS TO CONGRESS.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR MUST NOT
GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS
LAWYERS AND HE SNEAKED PREVIEW A
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER'S
FINDINGS, AND THEY MUST NOT BE
ALLOWED TO INTERFERE IN
DECISIONS OF WHAT PARTS OF THOSE
FINDINGS ARE EVIDENCE ARE MADE
PUBLIC.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATIONS FOCUSED ON
QUESTIONS THAT GO TO THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR DEMOCRACY
ITSELF, WHETHER FOREIGN POWERS
CORRUPTLY INTERFERED IN OUR
ELECTIONS AND WHETHER UNLAWFUL
MEANS WERE USED TO HINDER THAT
INVESTIGATION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO THE TRUTH.
THE WATCHWORD IS "TRANSPARENCY."
SEPARATE FROM THAT, BRET, I
SPOKE ON THE PHONE TO A KEY
TRUMP ALLY ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE OF CAPITOL HILL WHO SAID
THE FACT THAT WE FOUND OUT THE
REPORT HAD BEEN SUBMITTED BUT
DID NOT INSTANTLY FIND OUT ABOUT
NEW INDICTMENTS, THIS LAWMAKER
THINKS, IS A POSITIVE STEP FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
AGAIN, REPUBLICANS SEEM PLEASED
AT LEAST FOR NOW THAT THE WORD